Now that you have seen how the, ROB based processor works,
when we have reservation stations for separate units separately,
let's talk about unified reservation stations. So, this is what we had so
far. We had three reservation stations for the add unit, and we had two for
the multiply unit. This also does subtracts, this also does divides. And
we have seen it in at least one of our examples that we can run out of
these reservation stations while we still have plenty of these left.
However, we still couldn't issue instructions. Basically, once we
cannot issue instruction because it needs one of these reservation stations,
because issue needs to happen in order. We cannot issue a new this,
either. So until these reservation stations become available,
we cannot really use the available ones here. Note that, these reservation
stations are exactly the same, except that this one is feeding this unit, and
this one is feeding this unit. But the logic in them is exactly the same.
They're monitoring all of the results that are broadcast, capturing results, and
then going to execution units. So to improve our ability to use the expensive
reservation stations. We can go with the so called unified reservation stations
approach. Where all of the reservation stations are in one big array. Now,
when we need to issue, we need to grab one of these reservation stations. But
it doesn't matter which unit it is for.
Basically all of the reservation stations are equal. So the benefit of
this is that, as long as there are any available reservation stations,
we can issue instructions. The drawback here is that the logic for dispatching
instructions into these execution units becomes a little bit more complication.
Here, for issue into the multiplication we only need it to see whether one of
these is available, and if, one or more or available, select one. Meanwhile,
here we're selecting one of these three. And sending it to the add you need.
And if more than one are available we have to figure out just which one of
the three. Here however, every cycle we need to select one of these, for
the add and one of these for the multiply, so we need to actually consider which
one of these are adds to go here, which one of these are multiplies to go here,
and then every cycle we need to select one of the adds and one of the multiplies
to go there. So, the logic for. Dispatching becomes more complicated here
because we have more reservation stations to look at. And we also for each unit
we need to look at reservation stations that just have wrong things for
that unit, so we have to ignore that. But again, reservation stations are very,
very expensive. So, usually processes will use some variant of this
organization rather than this one. Basically we don't have each unit. Having its
own reservation station's typically a group of units who have a reservation
station so that we can benefit from, our reservation stations if we have them.